for
e
good
morning good morning everyone
we meet here today to
discuss hamas's terror attack in Israel
and the humanitarian crisis in Gaza as
EU leaders met yesterday in an
extraordinary European council meeting
the alahi Arabi Baptist Hospital in Gaza
was bombed and hundreds of innocent
lives were lost the devastation of a
hospital is horrific and unjustifiable
and we must ensure we continue to shed
light on what happened as the tragedy in
the Middle East continues to unfold it
is once again the innocent who are
forced to pay the price we must remain
clear that protecting civilian lives
must keep being a priority we cannot
lose sight of the humanitarian
consequences this has always been our
core message so this house remembers the
victims as we keep pushing for a way
forward in the region I will now give
the floor to minister Alvarez for the
Council after which I will give the
floor to the high representative and
then the president of the commission
Minister the floor is
yours president of the European
Parliament president of the commission
High
representative ladies and
gentlemen this morning we woke up to the
news of the atrocious attack on the
alali hospital which has left which has
caused hundreds of Palestinian victims
hospitals and civilians cannot be a
Target the suffering of the civilian
population of Gaza needs to
end we
also are deeply moved shocked by the
terrible terrorist attack that Israel
suffered on the 7th of October
which caused over 2,000 dead and 200
hostages and we call for the immediate
and unconditional release of those
hostages we would like to express our
solidarity and support to the victims of
uh to the families of all victims their
loved ones and the friends of Israel and
Palestine I'd also like to express my
condolences to France Belgium and Sweden
for the terrible attacks suffered during
the last couple of days we need to
preserve cohesion
tolerance
and understanding in our society because
that is what Europe stands for this is a
very serious
situation and Europe needs to be
faithful to its principles supporting
the fight against Terror terrorism and
acting to support the civilian
population we need to fly the flag of
international
humanitarianism and we also need to fly
the flag of flag of Peace that's what
our citizens expect of
us and so do our friends and partners
across the
world
we firmly without ifs and buts condemn
these acts of terrorism and violence
barbarity cannot Triumph we recognize
Israel's def right to defend itself
against this terrorist
attack this
defense defense needs to take place with
the most scrupulous respect for
international humanitarian law the
civilian population cannot be a victim
we need to allow humanitarian access to
Gaza we need to ensure basic supplies
for the population water electricity
food
medicines we need at all costs to avoid
escalation in the humanitarian CR crisis
in Gaza our friends and partners across
the
world expect the voice and actions of
Europe to be raised and for us to act in
in accordance with that desire we cannot
allow the forc displacement of hundreds
of thousands of people we have to we
must at all times distinguish between
terrorist objectives and the civilian
population assistance and cooperation
from Europe to to the Palestinian
National Authority and the people of
Palestine shouldn't be interrupted in
fact it should be boosted and therefore
the commission announcement to of the
tripling of humanitarian assistance is
very important that's what our citizens
expect and that's what our partners
across the world expect with that goal
Spanish assistance will be further Prov
providing a further 4 million euros to
Palestine by the end of the year added
to the 21 million already provided
humanitarian
principles need to be emphasized
clearly in the same way as we affirm and
continue to affirm our condemnation of
terrorism and Israel's rights to defend
itself against terrorism because that is
precisely what
distinguishes nations that love peace
from terrorists we need to differentiate
between Hamas and the Palestinian people
and the N Palestinian National Authority
we shouldn't confuse Hamas with the
legitimate leadership of the
Palestinians the Palestinian Authority
has for a long time been Europe's
partner for peace Hamas does not
represent the Palestinian people during
these terrible moments we must at all
costs avoid the regional extension of
the conflict Europe and Spain are
committed to peace and stability in the
region our number one goal needs to be
maintaining peace and stability in the
West Bank and in Lebanon the situation
in Lebanon is of particular concern this
is a fragile country the UN Force
commanded by the Spanish General Lazaro
is doing extraordinary work in very
difficult circumstances to comply with
its mandate and maintain stability in
the region
Europe needs to stand should
shoulder-to-shoulder with Lebanon basing
ourselves on an agenda of peace and
stability we need a vision of Lebanon as
a state which is the necessary condition
for the people there to be able to face
the
challenges that they face that they have
we cannot allow anyone to make use of
this tragedy for their own
ends but we also today need to start
thinking about
the day when this SP new latest spir of
violence ends we need to put an end to
this tragedy which has taken place to
many
times we need to
find a solution for once and for all the
two-state solution Israel and Palestine
living in peace and security one next to
the other and this requires a definitive
agreement in line with agreements that
have already been signed and parameters
agreed since the during the conference
in Madrid once we overcome this crisis
we need to move forward with this agenda
urgently emotions are running high and
sometimes these emotions are
contradictory and it's precisely because
of that that we need to be particularly
responsible and particularly careful
with regard to what we say and how we
say it when we say it
too
Europe firmly condemns terrorism and
violence and we'd like to express our
solidarity with the victims without
distinguishing between their religion
and nationality Europe is mobilizing to
promote firm humanitarian action based
in the Universal values of humanity
Europe needs to act together to demand
that this tragedy is not repeated and
this will only be possible if we can
offer the Palestinian people and also
also the people of Israel a perspective
based on a credible and definitive peace
and
this requires a two-state
solution the Israeli State and the
Palestinian State living together in
peace and security that's what the
peoples of the region and the world have
wanted for decades I firmly believe
that our friends in the region and our
citizens expect Clarity and firmness
from the European Union a firm
commitment against terrorism against
violence a firm commitment to peace to
Justice to
humanity and we need to come together
with all parties and with our Arab and
international Partners to ensure that
this genuinely is the last time thank
you thank you very much minister I give
the floor now to the high representative
for foreign affairs yes Borel yes you
have the
floor president of the parliament
president of the commission
Minister ladies and
gentlemen These are times of high
emotion feelings are running very high
we need
to call to the voice of reason here we
need to move past the emotions that are
caused by the tragic events that we've
been
seeing we've all firmly condemned the
Indescribable horror of the attacks
suffered by
Israel the attacks against the civilian
population which left so many dead
that have affected so many defenseless
people when they were celebrating
life and they suddenly found themselves
faced with
death let's say it
again let's condemn these attacks again
and let's say that of course Israel has
the right to defend
itself anyone attacked in this brutal
manner would have that
right
I think we also stand together to say
that the right to defend yourself like
all rights has limits and these in this
case are marked by international law in
particular International humanitarian
law all of this is
clear and we can repeat
it but repeating
us will bring us
nowhere
yes we condemn these terrible terrorist
attacks but I think we also have to
condemn the
civilian
victims that we've we have in Gaza now
there are around 3,000 of them because
condemning one tragedy shouldn't prevent
us speaking out against
another we condemn the terrorist attacks
but that doesn't stop
us showing our feelings for other
victims these are tragic
times and I think that at this time the
European Union needs to base its
response on four principles firmness
Humanity
consistency and a
proactive political attitude to the
conflict being firm begins with a clear
condemnation of
Hamas and as the minister said they
should not be identified with the people
of Palestine for us Hamas is a terrorist
organization and they've shown that
we're quite right to call them that with
their acts of recent days Hamas has been
boycotting any effort to make peace it
stood against un resolutions it stood
against resolutions from the Arab League
which provided a possible path to peace
between Israel and
Palestine Hamas wants to eradicate
Israel from the map they don't want
peace they want
destruction but
it's becoming impossible for the
Palestinians to achieve a fair peace
they're also the victims of
Hamas but we can't make the Palestinian
people and the inhabitants of Gaza can't
be made responsible for the terrorist
actions of Hamas being firm also means
calling for the release of the hostages
and this links in with our
second principle for Action which is
Humanity Wars also have rules Wars are
terrible
things and what we've
seen
this bomb bomb explosion in the hospital
which we don't yet know to whom should
it should be attributed is another
terrible manifestation of what goes on
but War has to be carried out in line
with
International rules and we've said it in
other contexts cutting water supplies
and food off from civilian populations
isn't in line with the rules of War
there's no water coming to Gaza now
over 3,000 dead over a quarter of them
children we cannot make the people of
Gaza responsible for the a terrible
actions of
Hamas the third
principle political
coherence and I think it's fair to say
that all of us agree on what I've just
said we reject
Hamas and we want to see International
humanitarian law respected by all sides
we want to see attacks against
defenseless civilians end regardless of
where they are and we need to ensure
that the actions of member
states are in line with the common
action of the European Union and we need
to ensure that EU policies are in line
with what we want to see and this raises
the issue of assistance to the
Palestinian
Authority and the issue of humanitarian
assistance to the victims in Gaza and
the decision of the president of the
commission to multiply our humanitarian
Aid by three is a good example of this
political coherence unfortunately
obviously humanitarian assistance needs
to get into Gaza and it can't at the
moment because all ways in are closed
the Egyptian foreign minister has asked
again and again for the
bombardments against infrastructure to
stop so that humanitarian Aid could go
into Gaza the fourth
principle is the one that we need to
invest most political energy into I
think which is a proactive attitude to
resolve the
conflict I was in Gaza in
2008 during the attacks that took place
then I've
now observed four Wars like this one and
I firmly believe that if if we don't
stop the cycle of violence it'll happen
again in a few years time we need to end
this conflict between Israel and pal
Palestine because peace between Arab
countries and Israel which is good
news doesn't automatically bring peace
between Israel and Palestine which needs
to be
achieved an Israeli
reservist who was called up said to the
press that the most powerful Army to
defend his country would be
peace while there's no peace there'll be
no Army that's powerful enough to
guarantee Israel's
peace but peace will not come about
automatically peace has to be built we
should recognize that the International
Community of which we're a part has not
done everything necessary to ensure that
the Oslo agreements agreements which
which are now 30 years old be
implemented we've on a daily basis
called for a two-state solution but as
the UN
stated what are you doing to achieve
that apart from calling for it since
Oslo the
number of settlers in the occupied
territories has multiplied by three
and the geographical area for a possible
Palestinian state has been cut to a
series of nonconnected
areas the
solution seems far away and it looks
difficult to implement but we don't have
any any
alternative if there aren't two states
there'll just be one and how would
people live in this single state how
would people live together what would
the conditions for life
be we have one solution so we need to
mobilize our political energy of which
we have a great deal in Europe to build
it normalization with of relations with
Arab countries is not
enough and with this attack it's
possible that Hamas wanted to provoke an
Israeli attack which would make it
impossible to have normal relations
between Israel and Saudi Arabia that may
well have been one of its strategic
objectives it wasn't simply a crazy
attack it's a strategy to prevent moves
towards
peace we've been working with our
special Envoy for the Middle East Sven
kman we've been working with Jordan
Egypt the Arab League Saudi
Arabia to
relaunch a process that can lead us to
this two-state
solution we need to recalibrate and
increase our efforts in the United
Nations there are 60
countries all of them in favor of this
solution so today we should commit
ourselves to this and this would be the
best way of honoring the dead on both
sides we should commit ourselves to
building peace which requires political
a political framework that has already
been agreed the UN resolutions necessary
already in place all it needs is a
political boost which Europe can make a
contribution
to in the security Council today we'll
be
debating a resolution presented
yesterday yesterday by Brazil which will
be voted on today and what will
be what we vote on in the security
Council and the way in which we
communicate on the conflict is going to
determine Europe's role in the world for
many years to come this morning I heard
the mosque
of Alazar in Egypt and uh there's a
great deal of concern now because what
they said shows that we're moving
towards a conflict between the Muslim
and Christian worlds and we can't have
that because Security on our streets
depends on us preventing
that geopolitics depends on us
preventing that conflict we've made
massive efforts to preventing the
conflict moving further to being
extended towards Lebanon I've spoken to
many
ministers during recent
days in Aman we achieved achieved a
joint communication between the
countries of the gulf and the countries
of the European Union and I think it's
that communication that should guide our
action
humanity and a political commitment to
moving out of this solution and building
a lasting peace that's what we should be
doing thank you presentative I give the
floor now to the president of the
European commission
[Applause]
Vine Madame President dear
Roberta High representative josep
Minister
Alvarez Hamas Terror has plunged Israel
and Palestine into a new spiral of
violence
last night a senseless tragedy has
shocked us all a hospital in Gaza
Sheltering hundreds of wounded people
was turned into a hell of
fire the scenes from Al Ali Hospital are
horrifying and
distressing there is no excuse for
hitting a hospital full of
civilians all facts need to be
established and those respons
responsible must be held
accountable in this tragic hour we must
all redouble our efforts to protect
civilians from the fury of this
war and let me express my
condolences to the families of the
victims of the terrorist attacks in
Brussels and
Aras tragically we see that terror is
resurfacing
again it is also Terror that brings us
here to this debate the heus terror
attacks of Hamas on
Israel what we have seen in the kibuts
AA is pure
evil the blood witness of horror the
burned
houses the abandoned children's toys
that no child would touch ever
again Hamas terrorists slaughtered over
1,400 men women children and B babies in
one day for one single
reason because they were
Jews just living in the state of
Israel with the explicit goal to
eradicate Jewish
life Israel has the right to
self-defense in line with international
law Hamas are terrorists and the
Palestinian people are also suffering
from that Terror and we have to support
them and there is no
contradiction in standing in solidarity
with Israel and acting on the
humanitarian needs of the Palestinian
people I have visited Israel many times
in my
life but this time I saw a nation that
is shocked to the core I was struck to
hear the same request from all the
people I spoke to from president
president hatuk prime minister Netanyahu
all forces in the unity government from
families of the
abducted they all asked for
solidarity and clear
words and this is the least we can do
for the people of
Israel this horror calls for a United
response from us as human
beings as Defenders of a free
world as Europeans where hate Terror and
racism have no place Europe stands with
Israel in this dark
moment this is the essential starting
point and I believe it was important to
pass this message of solidarity in
person in Israel just days after the
attack only only if we acknowledge
Israel's pain and its right to defend
itself will we have the
credibility to say that Israel should
react as a democracy in line with
International humanitarian
law and that is
crucial to protect civilian lives even
and especially in the middle of a
war we first have to
listen if if we want to be listened
to and indeed during my visit I
discussed Israel's efforts to protect
civilian
lives there can be no hesitation on our
side Europe will always be on the side
of humanity and of Human
Rights allow me to update you on our
work to address this dramatic situation
and the broader crisis that Hamas has
Unleashed let me begin with the
humanitarian situation which is getting
worse by the
hour humanitarian Aid must urgently
reach
Palestinians this is why we have decided
to immediately triple our humanitarian
Aid to civilians in Gaza and we have
launched an EU humanitarian air bridge
to Egypt to bring life saving supplies
to humanitarian organizations on the
ground in
Gaza the first two flights are taking
place already this
week carrying humanitarian cargo from
UNICEF we have deployed our staff and we
are working with un agencies to
ensure that this Aid can reach those in
need the European Union has always been
the largest International donor to
Palestine
and this will not
change but as the situation on the
ground
evolves it is also
essential that we urgently and carefully
review our financial assistance for
Palestine EU funding has never gone to
Hamas or any terrorist
entity and it never will what Hamas has
done has nothing to do with a legitimate
aspirations of the Palestinian people so
it was good to hear president abas clear
words that come came out on Sunday
evening my second point is about the
regional
situation Hamas actions have major
geopolitical
implications we know that they risk
affecting the historic rapo between
Israel and the Arab
countries but there there is nothing
inevitable inevitable in
this instability can be
contained dialogue between Israel and
its neighbors can and must
continue so this time of war must also
be a time of unrelenting
diplomacy a moment to engage even more
closely with Israel and with other
countries in the
region I have been recently talking to
several Arab
leaders including the King of
Jordan the president of the UAE as well
as the President of
Egypt all were very clear about the
importance of our EU
funding and the European Union with its
massive funding we are the largest donor
has not only leverage but also has a
stake in it
and thirdly we are seeing a rise in
anti-semitic incidents including here in
Europe synagogues have been
vandalized hate speech and fake news are
spreading at worrying speech
speed and this is something that we
simply cannot accept it is our shared
responsibility to make sure that our
dark past does not return we have to
protect Jewish life in
Europe in these years we have put the
fight against anti-Semitism and all hate
crimes at the heart of our
action thanks to our Collective work on
the Digital Services act we now have
laws to take down illegal content
online and contain the spread of
disinformation and we are now using them
for the first time ever we have already
launched an investigation in relation to
X formerly known as
Twitter they must comply with the
obligation to counter the spread of
terrorist propaganda and hate
speech because in Europe there is no
place and zero tolerance for hate
whether online or in our
streets we have also stepped up our work
to ensure the physical security of
Jewish
communities we have already increased EU
funding for the protection of places of
worship such as
synagogues and at the beginning of the
Mandate we propos to add hate crime
and hate speech to the list of EU crimes
that must be sanctioned all across our
Union our proposal is still blocked by
some member
states but it cannot wait any longer it
is time now for member states to act and
to move
on Europe's history is a history of
diversity among others Jewish culture
has for centuries enriched our common
European
culture and this must continue to be the
case European Jews must be
free to wear Kea or Star of David in our
streets and to light our cities with the
candles of hanuka in their
windows and every European must be free
from Fear
we must make good on Europe's promise to
be United in
diversity to be a safe place for all
Europeans honorable members this is the
moment for all of us to come together to
join forces Against Terror in all its
forms and to do what is
right I will go now back to Brussels to
join a commemoration ceremony for the
victims of the recent terror attack in
Brussels I thank you for your
attention thank you very much and now we
go to the speakers of the political
group starting with the EP group
president Manfred
[Applause]
beber president of parliament commission
High representative dear Minister dear
colle
Al why do we have today's debate on
October the 7th Israel was attacked
Israel was attacked